I want to talk about the troops because
we were um we were talking about
mandatory vaccinations for the US
Military and what most people told us is
they assumed that if you're in right now
and you said I won't get vaccinated you
would get an administrative discharge
did you have you heard anything like
that that's that's uh UCMJ 92.
well it depends
um you know it's that essentially is is
more of a decision made by the military
but but it would be fair to file orders
so they could give you administrative
discharge which is uh sort of like the
medium so there's honorable of course
honorable discharge
um there's administrative there and then
there's other honorable oh so
dishonorable isn't the exact word
there's other than honorable other than
honorable is that a new phrase no I I
put it before I just didn't know it was
formal so we had the story from Daily
Mail Biden says troops should be
honorably discharged at least Hunter I
believe Hunter has actually got an admin
discharge as well it makes sense yeah
Biden says troops should be dishonorably
discharged if they did disobey order to
get covet vaccines the house is using
the wrong phrase the house is set to
vote on the ndaa the pentagon's annual
defense budget so they mandated all 1.4
million service members get vaccinated
an amendment passed during committee
markup prohibits giving service members
who refuse a vaccine anything but an
honorable discharge White House said
that commanders must have the ability to
give orders and take appropriate
disciplinary measures including
enforcing the vaccine mandate the White
House also took issue with the section
of Bill that exempts those who had the
previous Covenant infection from the
vaccine mandate now that is insane so a
dishonorable discharge the difference
the difference between that is
disarmable discharge means you it can
only be administered by a court-martial
so that means you you're actually going
into a military trial uh that you've got
a Jag you've got a military judge Etc
you are facing charges uh and then that
whole process plays out so the other
ones that we were talking about were are
forms of administrative but for
dishonorable discharge I mean there's
medical disc yeah a lot of people
obviously if you know you can get
discharged for various reasons not
always something like negative and then
when you when you leave if you want to
retire if you want to resigner for an
officer that's still considered a
discharge or discharge by itself doesn't
necessarily mean something negative
occurs if you're uh if you're an officer
everyone is discharged right right if
you're an officer and you resign it's
honorable yes yeah so the anything other
than honorable discharge would be not uh
dishonorable discharge that's a
different thing there's no cart martial
what I'm saying is yeah dishonorable
discharge means that you've gone through
Court martial and you you are out so if
you're having anything other than
honorable discharge without a court
martial is that what you're saying right
that would all fall under very these
various forms of administrative
discharge so it doesn't seem like the
people who refuse the vaccine as of
right now will be dishonorably
discharged no but Biden wants that to be
the case but he says he wants it so that
means that means he wants to it you know
to carry out what he said I don't think
he understands what he's talking about
even though uh he had two sons in the
military
um he doesn't seem to know very much
about the military what do you do when
your commander surrenders a war that
you're winning and then makes horrible
decisions after that
yeah you transfer to the Air Force yeah
but I mean legit is the generals in the
Army when the commander does that what
are you supposed to do
uh well if it's Rome um the centurions
would you know go to the you know go to
the senator or go to the emperor and and
demand some form of tribute the
praetorian guard of course would go and
demand a form of tribute from them well
like what are the generals supposed to
do if Biden he surrendered us to F the
the Taliban and now he's like I I I'm
saying I read more and more I think that
was on purpose huh I really I just more
and more you learn about what's going on
with the with the mineral deposits the
deal from China coming with the Taliban
you know it's there there's I I wouldn't
I wouldn't want to say I believe it's an
entirely probable or or even likely but
there's that possibility Joe Biden's
done deals with China and his son and
he's hooking him up this is why I tell
people to take the Alaska pill because
we have so many mineral deposits under
our own soil that if we're worried by
the way about these deposits in
Afghanistan well guess what flood the
zone right if we're putting our own
minerals in this then we're gonna get
them they're going to be cheaper we're
going to be able to use them better we
don't need Afghanistan and it's going to
hurt them in the World Market too so we
need an authorization for use of
military force in Alaska invade Alaska
yeah we should invade Alaska occupy
Alaska nation building occupy yeah
nation building Alaska 100 all for it
100 dude you know last time I was on
here we talked about this these towns
out there the poverty is insane it's
it's a it's a nice thought it really
really is I think it would require a lot
of private sector movements however in
terms of any kind of actual military
operation I gotta say this story about
vaccinating our our military
the military is being purged and the
police departments are being purged I I
mentioned this video every often every
so often where I think it was in
Portland there were these uh antifa
people stalking the guy who and they
were yelling at each other as he slowly
walked backwards he had some kind of bat
or or bar and the police pulled up
ordered him on the ground and arrested
him
the guy who was actually being harassed
and and you know I wasn't was trying to
defend himself right and then he
apologizes to anti-fussing sorry about
that you know
is what happens when the police who are
good are like I refuse to enforce this
stuff they quit what's left
behavioral sync police officers woke
police officers when the military says
if you defund the police you're going
the only police you're going to have are
the bad cops because all the good ones
are going to leave that's why the police
but with the military they're doing the
same thing they tooker Carlson said
they're coming after what do they say
something like Christian conservatives
Christian conservatives so go back go
back to January I was reporting this
early on
um even before I was at human events and
I said this started with these
pre-screening of the National Guard
troops that were going to be occupying
the U.S Capitol prior to January 6. they
were out there with the the razor wire
the fencing that I had to drive past
every single day I couldn't even park my
car when I was going to the studio on
American News because these soldiers and
they were asking me for my
identification papers for my papers just
so that I could go to work at the same
place that I had worked for years right
and they would say why are you filming
why are you filming I'm a reporter I
work for one America news do you have uh
you know credentials I was like well I
do but I'm also on a public Street in in
the nation's capital yeah right but so
one of the things that came out was
remember they were pre-screening people
that were deployed to the capital and
what were they looking for they were
looking foreign flags gads and flags
Maga hats Turning Point USA NRA yeah you
know all these just like like a Virginia
basic or a symbol in Virginia they use
on the license right right these very
basic symbol symbols of American
conservatism or patriotism and
americanism the Gadsden flag I don't
really think is I mean I know the
Libertarians try very hard to uh to
claim it but it really is just an
American symbol at the end of the day
symbol of Independence and that phrase
don't tread on me that's that's Ben
Franklin that was the idea that because
the rattlesnake was such a North
American uh creature that he said you
know this was something that should be
that we should use because it's ours and
the British don't have it and so you get
all these uh conservatives who are very
confident that they would win against
the left
one of the original memes of America if
you will except it's not true because if
it ever comes down to any kind of real
kinetic Warfare the entire military and
the police departments will be wokified
by then and there are a lot of people
who are like I would never follow those
orders yeah that's right and they
court-martial you or throw you out and
then the remaining woke lemming NPC
soldiers would do whatever they're told
like they did in DC well and remember
they're not going to be told that
you know oh hey these are just regular
American citizens they're going to be
told these are extremists these are
crazy and right if they are far right
anti-vax
um conspiracy nut jobs who believe that
they want to overthrow the country they
are planning an Insurrection and you
need to uh go in and infiltrate this
group with you know and get them to
commit crime so that we can bring them
up on charges and you get to egg them on
and egg them on and then we're going to
arrest them all and you are saving the
country by doing this you see that event
in DC where it was for the j6 defendants
but everybody was a Fed right yeah it
was the funniest thing Fort Fisher got
the uh got the footage right so a Fed
actually was there and got arrested the
funny thing is it's like when you have a
large crowd of thousands of people and
there's like seven feds there you won't
notice they they all look fairly similar
and they're kind of obvious sometimes
but you got so many people everywhere
but when no one shows up and the only
people there are feds they all look
identical they're wearing khaki shorts
with the sides of their head heads shave
the same haircuts the same sunglasses
the same watches and it's like what is
this sidearm greetings fellow
insurrectionists right right how are you
planning any insurrections and uh there
was a one guy who got arrested
and the police surround him because he
had a gun and he's like my badge is in
my pocket and they pull out a badge some
people claimed he was undercover but
others claimed he was just an officer
who was there and I think the left was
trying to frame it as federal agents are
Maga cultists and they're at these
events or was he recruiting
recruiting or is recruiting in what
capacity like trying to get more feds
try any right trying to get him this
this is the way it works right the
federal informant is not typically a
federal agent right right so a federal
informant is someone who has a
relationship with a federal agent which
is known as a source and a Handler or an
informant Handler right you're being run
that's what that's the parlance you're
being run by that agent so they're not
going to get somebody who has a badge
and stick them in the group and have
them like you know like Ian is not going
to be you know you know the agent but
Ian's going to be the one talking to the
agent I saw those signal messages it's
all theoretical by the way
uh big graphene I'll talk to anybody man
let's heal this Earth hey man we're just
talking we're just talking but no so the
way it works is and then that and you've
seen this by the way in the Michigan
Governor operation and I'm calling it
the operation because that's what it was
the the text messages have been coming
out where you can see the relationship
it is being driven by the agent where
they're telling people to egg things on
to egg things on and to use the legal uh
the legal phrase you have to commit a um
a conspiracy commit a crime what you
need to do is you know to of course
first come up with the plan and then you
need to take an overt action in
furtherance of the conspiracy so what it
was in the Michigan plot was because if
you're just talking about stuff okay
that's just talk you can't make a case
on that but and again I'm talking about
the legal you know situation so what
they do is they say hey we're gonna go
get in the car and we're gonna go do
Recon and he says get everybody you can
tell him sad or whatever the day you can
he says what's better what should I go
Saturday or Sunday WHo responds go
whichever day you can get the most
people
get them all in the car because the
agent knows that this is the way the
rules work so that if whoever's in that
car then and they're going around and
they're like taking pictures around the
lake but it just so happens that this is
the lake where the governor's mansion is
and so they can then put on paper this
was an overt act in further into the
conspiracy what if like you showed up
with a bunch of pizzas and you're like
hey guys I brought a bunch of pizzas for
us to eat and hang out and they're like
that's a planning meeting
um
you'd have to you no no I don't have to
be in furtherance of the crime right you
know so that's just that's just the
eating dinner people need to understand
when it comes to talking to Cops and
fads and all that stuff they don't care
about you they will use you and by the
way one of those things to your point
one of those stories one of the
informants is getting brought up on
charges yep you know so this is a guy
who was in on the operation but um and
of course the you know the speculation
is that maybe they're not being as as
forthcoming maybe they're not willing to
testify like they were and now guess
what they're getting cyber charges too
there's a there's a bunch of stories
about this and I won't get any specifics
because I'm just talking to Michigan you
know like privacy details and stuff but
there are there are big stories over the
past 10 years with Federal informants
who cooperated and everything right and
then immediately once was over got
arrested and charged a lot of this a lot
of this was done during the early 2000s
in the war on terror and it was it was
young Muslims in the United States
American citizens who thought they were
talking to you know Moss or Hezbollah or
Al-Qaeda and then eventually Isis but it
always ended up being federal agents
we're posing I mean like there are
people
who have been contacted by the feds and
they'll be like would you like to help
us stop this crime and they'd be like
yes I will help you and then they start
saying like you know let me know what
you need they start working with the
feds to get them information and then
the feds come and arrest them like the
people like when they come to you and
say we're gonna have you be an informant
it's quite possible you're being
investigated and they want you to say
things oh yeah they can lie to you oh
yeah and yeah yeah you're an informant
tell us what's going on but yeah so they
were saying this they were doing this
we're doing it like this guy was
organizing you you want to you want to
serve your country right yep you you
care about your country don't you you're
Patriot right right you're not you're
not one of those those traitors all
right all right you wouldn't do that you
wouldn't you wouldn't lie to a police
officer would you I was I was you
wouldn't download a TV would you I was
kidding one of my lie detector tests one
of my polygraphs that you have to do
um the the guy was so they do this thing
where
you know that's supposed to be like the
test right before they get into the real
questions and then they say um you know
the guy was like no I just you want to
get the Baseline and so I just wanted to
check so they ask you questions that uh
they assume you're going to lie on so
that they can get a baseline of what you
re what you're reading is is a lot and
keep in mind the machine wait they ask
you something they think you'll lie
about right like what so the question he
asked was you've never lied to your
parents have you
that's a good one yeah do people say I
haven't lied to my parents right because
of course they're thinking then that
it's going to trigger response of well
of course it wouldn't lie to appearance
but actually the one that he asked me he
would go um and he prefaced it he goes
you know I'm a prior state trooper and
boy when I would pull somebody over for
speeding
oh my gosh you know I would know how
fast they went but I'll tell you what
if they were honest with me and if they
said you know what officer I was going a
little fast back there I'm sorry about
that I would usually let them off with a
warning but if somebody lied to me if
somebody had the audacity to just lie to
my face and disrespect me like that I
was coming after them you you would
never do that right you you would never
lie to a police officer right so keep in
mind understand what they're doing
they're priming you right so you're
being primed to say oh my gosh I'm going
to be in trouble if I tell this guy who
keep in mind he's he's the evaluator of
the test and the Proctor the administer
of the test right so he's grading my
answer to that is I'm I'm gonna be
honest it's kind of confusing I'm not
quite sure what
you were getting right honestly when you
when you when you make a really really
long question and then say you would
never do that I'm not quite sure what
that refers to you'd never lie to a
police officer would you I would not lie
to a police officer right and so the and
you you never have lied to police
officers or something like that right
and so so that's the idea is that you
know because they're they're trying to
Prime you into a situation where you're
going to tell and it's a way you know
it's a white lie obviously I lied to my
parents all the time
I'm lying right now
this sentence is a lie keep in mind
yeah there's there's machines can like
the essential question is that you know
a machine can't tell if you're lying
right like we don't have machines that
we I don't think we'll ever have
machines that could do that what does it
do it measures your heart rate it
measures your respiration uh measure
there's there's um little clips that
measure your sweat you know we've went
across your uh your chest one kind of
across your lap do you have one that
you're like sitting on a pad so they're
measuring various uh your physiological
signs but it can't tell if you're yeah
they're just like they're trying to see
all these different stressors light up
right so they're they're trying to get a
reaction out of you and that I mean
they're inadmissible
the the LIE detectors to me which is why
they're inadmissible right because
they're fake right they're completely
fake it's just not real like but but but
I had a buddy who you know who's doing
that
um uh it was called pcass was one of the
systems and uh he was doing it overseas
for some Third Country Nationals that
were coming on base and so he was
um that would work as like other
International workers and so he was he
was doing pcass on them anyway you know
one thing he said was we are evaluated
not necessarily by the amount of people
that we conduct but we're actually
evaluated by the amount of elicitations
that come out of this because
essentially what you're doing is for for
most people you know for your general
Normie out there you're you're putting
them into this high stress environment
you're telling them that I will know if
you are lying so you better come clean
you better tell me so then they start to
ask a question and they say you know
have you ever taken home government
documents have you ever taken home
government resources and then they'll
say
I'm going to step away from the machine
for a second you know when I was asking
that question I could there was I was
getting
a weird reading and I wasn't really sure
what it was it just seemed like
something was registering with you just
as I was saying the question so is is
there something you want to tell me that
maybe could help me word the question
better so that this test this evaluation
can be more accurate to explain the
situation so if you just tell me that
I'll write it down and I'll I'll
refurbish this question and reevaluate
it for you and people spill their guts
yeah it just seems like polygraphs for
the most part are put people in high
stress situations where they think they
have to tell the truth right exactly and
it makes them panic and then it's just
it's not real yeah in interrogation it's
it's known as emotional fear up so it's
emotional fear up with you know uh you
know a very elaborate um I got a better
one what we'll do is we'll take two
gigantic metal discs hooked up with a
bunch of wires yes and we'll just and
we'll have them hook up the polygraph
and be like don't worry about the giant
metal discs they just blast you with
intense radiation whenever you lie oh
but you're not gonna lie so it doesn't
matter yeah yeah you know if you're not
gonna lie then you're gonna die from
radiation actually just step out for a
second we just gotta test them but every
time you lie and grab the sponge every
time you lie you have to eat polonium
just so you know there's a little bit
just a little bit a little bit no no a
lot we wouldn't make you a lot of them I
mean like a tiny little bit
wouldn't a tiny little [ __ ]
integrating your DNA or whatever yeah
completely not not immediately by the
way yeah that's what the didn't navalny
get polonium uh I don't know if it was
navalny I think it was it was um
somebody got pulled no that's great pal
it was it was in the UK yeah it was one
of the ones that they had ascribed to
polonium's radium disintegration by
synthetically bombarding bismuth with
lead or bismuth or lead with neutrons
you get this polonium stuff yeah it's
radiation it's radioactive yeah it goes
into your body
it's not it's not immediate or anything
but but yes so it's not it's like it's
like ricin which would be much more
immediator yeah people got to pay
attention to the stuff they eat man
because something number one yeah yeah
that's why when I hear people say that
hey man it comes from the earth I'm like
I don't know man a lot of stuff comes
from the earth that's not exactly the
best argument yeah I don't uh people
send me food in the mail and I'm just
like oh that's really great I throw in
the trash okay I'm like what am I gonna
do give it to somebody else but some
people might take it and be like no I'll
keep it I'll be like okay that's your
choice but you're like I went through a
phase where I would read all the
ingredients and if I saw something I
didn't know I'd look it up online and
read how does this interact with my body
and I'd Read All About It Good Question
yeah I'm just that's great that's great
by the way yeah that's that's good
Donald Trump would only eat fast food
you know why
that's exactly why because when you go
to a place and you ask someone to
prepare food for you he wouldn't like
exclusively but almost exclusively he
was eating fast food and there are two
big reasons I was told by some people in
the Press Corps was one he was a
germaphobe he is he felt like these fast
food chains had standards and so that if
he ate from these places there was at
least it was less likely that he would
get sick compared to going to any other
restaurant
two when you walk in and say I want a
Big Mac it's pre-made and sitting right
there so no one could spit in his food
or smear stuff on it or do something
gross Super Troopers yup yup and there
are a lot of people who don't like the
man but more importantly it's a
celebrity so a lot of people might you
know what's on the keys going in himself
too or what well it's not like he's
going in himself too
right but it's just when they already
have the Big Mac sitting on that little
warmer and you order a Big Mac and Fries
they just go right I've actually so
there was that um I know people saw that
that tweet that um I had tweeted a
picture of him out um and it was
actually he was with Throne Parnell but
then I clipped I cropped Sean out sorry
Sean him super thin um and it was like
he was looking really thin and I and I
just tweeted out he how is he getting
younger right so it went kind of viral
and then
I get an envelope at the studio down in
DC and and I open it up and it's it's a
note from it says from the desk of
Donald J Trump he's printed out my tweet
and then and then and then written
thanks Jack you are looking great too
wow the great work and they decided
Donald Trump so when you when you
absolutely have to respond to it too so
then I tweeted that out which I I have
to look into the process but some people
are saying like that should definitely
be your nft jack like that oh yeah that
tweet of Trump's printed out tweet that
he responded to you which Then I then
tweeted
yeah that's amazing so it's like when
you when you absolutely have to comment
on a tweet yeah but you're not on
Twitter how do you do it let's talk
about one of the things oh sorry sorry
the um the little bit of the backstory
though was I was told not by him but
someone else I was discussing this all
with that they are start that they are
they he's cutting down on the fast food
I was told that he's cutting down on the
fast food
um and it's doing keto uh more steak a
lot they said hey man eat more steak and
he was like sure I'll eat more steak why
not you know that sounds like a good
diet they said yeah you gotta get all
that sugar is that Mar-A-Lago he's at
Bedminster he's at Trump Tower so I mean
it's his right it's it's restaurants
that he controls it's his staff Etc you
know you know people need to understand
about uh Ketone stuff
a lot of the garbage you eat is the
processed breads grains sugars and I've
noticed that when I've been trying to
stay away from all the sugars I'm also
staying away from processed foods yes so
it's a lot more uh fresh chicken breast
a lot more roast beef my fresh cheeses
we have raw cheeses so my wife's family
um and my wife of course they're from
from Eastern Europe when they come to
the U.S they like my father-in-law like
he will not eat the processed food here
he looks at it and said this is not food
like this is not this is plastic this is
fake I don't know what this is but you
go to he gets something from
um Whole Foods or the butcher or
something that they get and they cook
themselves okay this is food right
um but when it comes to the processed
stuff like I've seen him just you know
you know we'll have some chicken nuggets
for like the kids or something and hey
do you want one of them no like just
emphatically I just had a feeling that
uh grain-fed beef maybe isn't as keto as
grass because grain is if it's eating
grain its whole life then maybe it's got
some some stuff in it that's not well
you do have to watch for I was actually
tweeting about this earlier today like
if you're eating beef you have make sure
you're not eating double plus good beef
um because because there are uh at some
of these factory farms they're depending
on what they feed that's why you want
um free range grass-fed because they are
feeding
these cows
um corn you know corn and stuff with all
this estrogen and putting all sorts of
additives into to make it bigger to make
it juicier to make it last longer but
guess what it's also not healthy that's
right they feed salmon farm salmon is
fat corn yeah and then I read I read
that like in nature salmon turns pink
because of the Krill and stuff that it
eats or whatever right in farms they're
fed corn so they're gray so they have to
add food coloring gross yeah amazing
isn't it I almost just spit out my
coconut that's gross food coloring bad
all right we got some thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time